Diana Walker why did you call your book
public and private well that's an easy
question because the book consists of
pictures I took with the regular white
house press corps which are in public so
to speak and then the other part of the
book of pictures I took where I had
exclusive access and they are the more
private pictures on the cover are two
sets of pictures we start up here at the
top with george bush and mr. Gorbachev
did you make the selection to put this
on front yes I did we were looking at
the pictures trying to decide what what
to put on the cover to sort of show you
the public side and the private side and
the I had a series of pictures of
Gorbachev and bush from the mall to
summit and we liked the feeling of the
movement of it and I had this series
also of President Clinton and mrs.
Clinton and so it just seemed to be
bring you in somehow make it more
interesting i hope these pictures of
President mrs. Clinton were taken were
those were taken on a boat on the Chobe
River in Botswana did they know you were
taking these pictures know how far away
were you I was about Oh 20 feet they
knew I was with them certainly and I was
the only journalist on the boat with
them but I was not in front of them
Brian I was across the the top of the
boat I had decided kind of to step back
a little give everybody a little space
there was no need to be that close and I
was talking to mrs. Clinton's press
secretary Marcia Barry and suddenly this
whole scene occurred and I just lifted
up my camera with on much longer lens
than i usually use and shot that series
of pictures so I I don't think they were
aware of me but of course I don't know
in the middle of your book is this
picture and only one of the six women
is no longer with us that's right that's
mrs. Nixon Pat Nixon and in fact she
died just a few months I believe maybe
six weeks to two months after this
picture was taken at the dedication of
the Ronald Reagan Library when you look
at this picture and you remember knowing
these women start with Nancy Reagan give
us some background what you know about
her what I know about her is I spent a
great deal of time with her in the first
four years of the Reagan administration
following her really around the world on
her just say no campaign and I became
very fond of her very fond indeed what
about mrs. Johnson well I don't know
mrs. Johnson really because I didn't
cover the Johnson years but I've
photographed her subsequently and find
her enormously charming did you know
mrs. Nixon i did not i never met mrs.
Nixon what about mrs. Bush well mrs.
Bush of course I knew mrs. Bush when she
was a wife of the vice president for
eight years and then when she was wife
of the President of the United States
for four and I got to know her quite
well and enjoy her humor a great deal is
she any different when the cameras and
microphones aren't on no she's exactly
the same what you see is you know what
you get then there's rose on Carter and
mrs. Ford right well Rosalyn Carter I
when I first started taking pictures for
four time I was assigned a lot to cover
mrs. Carter because when when I came to
time the present President Carter was
wrestling with the iran-contra situation
I mean excuse me the Iran hostage
situation and it consumed his time in
his focus and so mrs. Carter traveled
for him a great deal and she went abroad
for him and she went to every primary
state where there was going to be a
primary for the election of 1980 and so
I followed her a lot
and I found her to represent the United
States with enormous grit and dignity do
you remember when this picture was taken
I remember that vividly yes what year
was it um 1985 I believe what do you
remember about the circumstances the
circumstances where the time had asked
me to do a lead picture in the magazine
on a cover story we were doing and the
cut line was going to be why is this man
so popular so it was like it was a
sitting a portrait session that I had
with President Reagan and I had just
come over to talk to him about sort of
what I was going to do with him and I
was going to ask him a lot of stories
that I knew that he could tell well
because I wanted to show his humor and
his charm that was that was part of my
mission in the sitting what was he like
when again you're just you know they're
not motion cameras or not microphones
you know I found him to be very much
like he was in public I never saw
President Reagan you know totally i
would say laid back he was always quite
formal behind the scenes end out front
but a formal in a very kind of graceful
way with his humor showed both behind
the scenes and I thought in public to
1992 this picture on Air Force one was
at the new 47 47 at that time yes it was
this picture i love this picture because
it's so much like everybody's family the
i had secured permission to be behind
the scenes for quite a lot of the
convention in Houston in 1992 following
george bush and we had just arrived on
air force one in houston for that
convention week and when i walked in the
living room of or office of Air Force
One there was Marvin bush trying to
corral everybody to get them ready to go
out the door mrs. Bush was already
dressed and going out the door and
President Bush just continued to sit at
his desk going over his notes for his
first speech completely oblivious to all
of this activity in the room I loved it
when did you start as a photographer
well when I was a child I took pictures
for fun and I didn't and in through high
school you know I did the high school
yearbook things like that but I didn't
start taking pictures professionally
until my early 30s and I first started
doing pictures of anything children's
Christmas of Christmas cause of
children's pictures or bar mitzvahs or
book jacket so that kind of thing and
then it taking pictures in Washington
led me into political coverage you know
if i lived in cleveland i might have
photographed you know something entirely
different but as you know the business
of washington is politics so that's
where i went what your parents do here
my father was a doctor as his father was
before him and my mother who is still
living had a dress shop in Georgetown
for about 20 years and I worked for her
for a while who's the name of it Dorcas
harden which was her name now somewhere
that in the back and I can't remember
not sure is it Gail tirana I was that
her name yes you give her credit for
introducing you to photography haha
aren't you good to have read it so
carefully Gail I was working for my
mother in the shop and we were raising
our two little boys Mallory and I and I
just I don't think I was terribly happy
doing what I was doing and Gail said you
know you really love taking pictures and
you do it in all in your spare time all
the time why don't you become a
professional photographer and I said how
I mean what do you do sounds stupid now
but I really honestly hadn't given it a
great deal of thought and she said I'll
go into business with you she'd been a
stylist for a wonderful photographer New
York called Bert Stern so we started
together and she would sort of do the
bookkeeping and I go out and shoot the
pictures
and that's how we started who who was in
this picture is fairly obvious that
picture was taken at the opening of the
museum part of the Kennedy Library in
Boston when I was covering President
Clinton and he went up for the opening
ceremony at John F Kennedy jr. Caroline
Kennedy and their mother yes what the
date on this was nineteen ninety-three
that's right what do you remember about
what you heard in and around this photo
you know I heard and heard very little I
saw nothing nothing except what you see
we had raced out of the vans you know in
the press corps that follows the
president we follow him in the motorcade
and our van is quite far back and when
we get to a place we have to run very
quickly with all of our equipment and
try and get into position to take a
picture and I had just arrived in fact
in and I didn't have a very good
position and I remember lift I was quite
we were quite far away and I remember
lifting up my camera and hoping I had
something because it all happened just
terribly quickly so inside of course we
had a lot more time and we were more
settled but this was this shot I just
sort of grabbed as we as we entered the
library on the previous page is a
picture in black and white and this is
in color of a large group of presidents
at the time President Nixon was alive
and that President Reagan was out and
about the date on this one is 1991 what
are the circumstances this was at the
dedication of the Ronald Reagan Library
in in California and I at the time was
covering President Bush's administration
and President Bush of course was a guest
at the dedication in the library Richard
Nixon yes I hardly saw Richard Nixon and
so I saw him on this day and I saw him
very occasionally in Washington and then
I covered his funeral Jerry Ford I
started taking pictures at the White
House when Jerry Ford was president just
popping in
out and of course I went back to see him
about this book and found him perfectly
wonderful Jimmy Carter he was really the
first president that I had a chance to
cover and I although I really started
with Rosalyn Carter I did see the
president quite a lot and was very
impressed with him now in this book
there are a number of liner notes that
are written by the individuals yeah
these pictures how did you get that well
what I decided was the National
Geographic and I decided that since
these pictures were really my personal
choices that's the the book is meant to
be well it is made up of pictures that I
just simply liked the best of the ones i
took over the years they are not
necessarily events I we didn't make the
book based on the most important
historical event we we based the book on
just pictures I I particularly i
particularly liked when you go to the
Nixon Library you see this all of these
statues Joe and lie and oz a tongue and
Khrushchev Brezhnev yeah Winston
Churchill and de Gaulle is a staged yes
it most certainly was it is the oddest
rum Brian it's a it's a room with these
statues in it that were put there by
Richard Nixon and he commissioned them
and he had them made and they're of all
the world leaders that he met with in
his lifetime and they brought the
presidents in to this room for a
portrait and it was the strangest
looking situation as you can see because
it seemed to me when I looked at the
picture when I got it back that each of
the living presidents of former
presidents kind of were totally in
character as to who they were and it was
just a very kind of a strange surreal
situation what do you make of the
expression on Richard Nixon's face and
the way he's standing there isn't it odd
I don't know what to make of it
I think it's I don't know what he's
thinking about in that picture but I
think you are attracted right to the
center and to him because he's looking
down and he's thinking and everybody
else is kind of self consciously
standing there not knowing exactly
what's going on in that room kind of a
camera do you use now and then because i
know this is over a lot of years well
I've always using the lens reflex
cameras canon cameras with autofocus for
my normal everyday coverage at the White
House but behind the scenes I use a much
quieter camera i use a rangefinder leica
so that i can be more unobtrusive and
qua does it mean single-lens reflex
cameras think I'm sorry a single lens
reflex camera is a camera that you're
actually seeing the scene the image
through the lens and it has a mirror
well it's it's a 35-millimeter camera
and you you can actually see exactly
what you're going to get and so when you
put longer lenses on and I bring you
much closer I see exactly what I'm going
to get when I put that lens on or if I
use a wider lens i can see exactly what
I'm going to see what's what is another
way a camera is made what would you call
it well I think the difference would be
a rangefinder camera or a single lens
reflex camera rangefinder camera you are
not looking through lens you're looking
through a box with images that come
together to help you focus instead of
images that come together through a lens
to focus I'm not very good at describing
this this is a black and white photo and
it was taken in 1998 where was it
that was in Ghana I was behind the
scenes with President and mrs. Clinton
on that entire trip to Africa and so I
had the luxury of being able to go to
outside the press pen to places where
the press wasn't positioned to take the
picture therefore I was able to get
behind him in this particular situation
rather than getting the front picture
it's a luxury to be able to shoot from
behind because obviously you may miss
all of the action but to me it was just
beautiful in that scene I don't know
there's me or whether it's been around a
lot but I seem to have seen this picture
many times yes you have why because a
Walter Cronkite used it in his memoirs
and david gergen used it in his and it's
been published because it won some
prizes that's why you've seen it before
back here you have james brady david
gergen attorney general nice at the time
probably not Attorney General was early
George Bush Vice President James becca
the third bud Benjamin CBS News Walter
Cronkite and Ronald Reagan yes how much
can you tell us about this picture do
you know what they were laughing aviat
no unfortunately one of my problems
although it's been a benefit to me I
think over the years is I can't hear
much when I'm taking pictures because
I'm concentrating so hard so when I was
allowed in that room after Walter
Cronkite had done his last interview
with a sitting president as the ahead of
as the anchor of the CBS Evening News I
was very determined when I walked in
that room to make a picture because this
was quite a collection of people it was
three months after the president became
was inaugurated and it was just before
the assassination attempt and of course
to know that then but it was a wonderful
scene and they were telling jokes and I
have absolutely no idea what the joke is
I couldn't hear it and I've asked every
member
of that group what the joke was and
everybody acts as if they don't remember
and I'm not sure they don't remember but
1989 how often do you find yourself in
this kind of a situation all the time
when you cover when you cover the White
House you always working in a group such
as this group I think we were watching
the Inauguration from the balustrade up
on the Capitol Steps looking down and
that's the way I generally work although
in this book I show you pictures I took
that way and then I show you two
pictures I took when I was the only
photographer in the room in the back you
think a lot of people but one I wanted
to ask you about was Jamie Lee Curtis
yes how does how does she fit into your
life well she took the picture of the
author's picture um but she she has been
um who is she who is she yeah who's
Jamie they could she's an actress I know
but I just wanted to make sure that it
wasn't somebody I know she's a
photographer too it's another talent
that few people probably know about her
but we met over our mutual interest in
photography where'd you meet remember
yes Ketchum Idaho and that is because
because we were both vacationing in
Ketchum Idaho let me show this picture
if we could this is the author's picture
what was that good it was taken where
yeah uh in her living room and does she
do professional photography no she
doesn't but she does photograph a great
deal particularly her own family and
friends would you rather take
photographs in black and white or in
color black and white why because I have
more freedom in black and white and i
also like what it looks like this is the
last picture in the book yes when was it
on january twentieth two thousand and
one President Clinton had seen George
Bush sworn-in president and he'd gone
out to Andrews Air Force Base
right inside that hangar behind him
there'd been a big goodbye rally to
President Clinton that was attended by
many many many people supporters and
members of his cabinet and he was
walking from that rally to the airplane
to be flown to New York and to go back
home and this picture the right one
before it yes well that picture was
taken I'd always wanted to be in the
Oval Office with a president the last
moments he was in the Oval Office and
that's what this is and President
Clinton had signed a letter to the
incoming president george bush which
he'd left on the desk which you can see
there in the picture and he turned and
went to the window and I've looked at
this contact sheet and there's exactly
one frame of him looking out the window
and then he turned and walked towards
John Podesta who was his chief of staff
and they put their arms around each
other's shoulder and they walked out to
the waiting press on the colonnade to go
over to the White House to greet
President Elect Bush and here they are
yes this was the coffee the morning just
before they left to go up for the
inauguration on the at the Capitol and
you don't hear them talk when you're
taking these pictures you can't hear
what they're saying Brian I get a sense
of what's going on of course I do I get
a sense of the drama of the moment or
the humor of the moment or whatever but
I've always made it a policy of not to
talk about what I heard frankly because
I might get it wrong you write it down
no this photograph was taken i assume
around the same time it was just a few
moments before the bushes arrived and
the president's photographer sharon
farmer and I were standing together and
we followed the Clintons towards the
East Room
Sharon looked at me and said I think
we've gone far enough and she was so
right it was the cue to stop and let
these people go on by themselves as they
walked around the floor of the first
floor of the White House for the last
time basically how many times have you
had a cover on Time magazine oh not that
often I could probably count them on two
hands sir maybe three what are you the
happiest with I mean they had no covers
are important but what went else are you
the happiest with the where you see your
photos end up oh well of course I like
doing covers but most of the kind of
work that I do is is more sort of
environmental work such as I put in the
book I'm happiest when I see the
magazine take a picture such as the
picture you're looking at now of gore
and play it across the page it's a huge
thrill to me let me make sure we get it
on the screen or so the audience can see
it let's go now there we have it this
picture is to me an extraordinary
picture and I'm very proud of it and
it's in fact not been published but it
is a picture of just before going back
to that january twentieth two thousand
and one just before the bush family
arrived at the White House before the
inauguration ceremony President Clinton
and Vice President Gore went upstairs
privately to the quarters and I was
waiting by the elevator when they came
down and I've looked through that window
in that elevator in the White House
before and I looked through it and there
was the face of Al Gore just before he
was to meet with the man who was to
become president who had beaten him you
take this with the flash no sir all my
black and white pictures are taken with
available light that's somewhat when I
was talking about the freedom of using
black and white how many people took
this picture so many people you can't
believe except my position was there
be different from everybody else's just
let me point out we pull back a little
bit where all the other photographers
are located down in this area and some
of them are photographers course they're
members of the convention doughnuts also
Brian there is a small pool of
photographers on the left side of the
stage I was with the vice president's
photographer on the right side of the
stage and so therefore my picture is
quite different from the publish
pictures did you carry at that time both
black and white and color I did that
night but generally I don't generally
when i'm doing a black and white picture
story that's all i have but i knew i'd
have an interesting perspective for a
picture that was quite public we used
the black and white for private pictures
for pictures that were exclusive to us
but that night I knew that I was both
going to see exclusive things and public
things and certainly on that stage that
was a public thing I first saw this I
thought it was a painting oh well it is
quite beautiful it it was a wonderfully
exciting moment for me it was the the
Queen's yacht the Britannia left from
Plymouth England to go over to Normandy
taking the leaders of what were the
Allied countries during the Second World
War over to the 50th anniversary of the
invasion of Normandy so I was there
because President Clinton was a guest on
the Britannia this is in 1997 where was
it yeah this was in a church it is i
think it's the practice of most
presidents to on Inauguration Day to
start their day off in church and this
was the Clintons and the Gores going to
an early morning service and the press
had left and I was crouched down by a
Pew and doing this behind the scenes
work and suddenly there was this
Reverend who was a great friend of the
Clinton family said something apparently
very very funny but don't ask me what it
was where's this that's a picture on
that same boat on
the chobe river in botswana and it had
docked it was in the evening and the
Clintons were just enjoying a
conversation with sandy Berger and our
ambassador to South Africa and our
ambassador to Botswana now did you think
about partisanship when you put this
book together we worried about people
seeing too much from one president not
another and how'd you do that well of
course I did think about that but I the
reason the book is starts with just a
few pictures of Ford and increases the
number of pictures over all of the years
so that the Clinton administration in
the end is the thickest chapter the
reason for that is that I think I became
a better photographer over the years at
least I hope I did and the pictures of
the Ford administration were really my
first foray and I took it as far as I
could go at the White House with the
behind-the-scenes work and so there are
more behind-the-scenes pictures of of
the Clintons than any other
administration may 21st 1992 Cleveland
Ohio well I had to put that in the book
because it's such an odd picture I
showed it to um President Bush and he
was he laughed and loved it just as I
did you know when a president goes
anywhere he stands in front of logos or
flags or whatever and this was the
ultimate big flag I had never seen a
flag that big and any photo op and in
any president I'd ever covered what did
they do with this photo at the time they
didn't run it no no what was what about
this one ha that was never never ran
either a lot of these pictures are new
to to anybody who's been watching why do
you like this one oh I just think it's
funny I love all the children and these
funny hands and the horse up here of
these kids so you can see what they love
them um it's just kind of here these
guys doing their their thing talking
policy and there are these little
children as a back
than they're all sort of in their own
world doing their own thing of all the
people you've taken photographs of over
the years who are the most natural with
other people with other people other
words when they see them it's not
awkward they are easy in conversation
they have good small talk put people at
ease that's hard for me to answer
because I think all of the presidents I
have covered have been pretty darn good
at that i would say going backwards
certainly President Clinton was very
adept at it very good very but so so was
President Bush perhaps President Reagan
was maybe slightly more removed and I
saw more of mrs. Carter than I did
President Carter and the Fords I never
really traveled with so I'm not very
good on that observation you made a
comment earlier that you've gotten
better over the years I hope so what
well how do you how can you tell uh well
I I think maybe people tell me that but
no I look at the early pictures of
Gerald Ford that I took and they're
they're pretty pedestrian there they're
pretty straightforward I I also cut off
his feet when he was walking and I
didn't have as much confidence in myself
to try different different angles or
different positions to shoot from I was
just a beginner 1984 this is a long time
ago it's not a bad picture who are these
people got lucky those do characters are
really awfully important characters
that's congressman Bella Abzug on the
left and betty Friedan in red and you
know when we go photograph any and the
president or this was a candidate Walter
Mondale running for president in 1984
you're always looking for the other
characters who are in the situation who
are on the stage who are in the Rose
Garden you're always looking for the
other people because they're important
and these two women who were incredibly
important in the
women's movement in the United States
were listening to vice president Mondale
and Geraldine Ferraro why Sam Donaldson
because I wanted a picture in the book
to show you the press in action because
I thought it was important and I'd I'd
shown you working journalists Raleigh
Evans and Novak and I had shown you my
group of photographers working and I
thought that a television personality
was important and he certainly was a big
player when I was there her block when
he died last year they're exactly the
date 50 million dollars he had earned
over the years he gave away to a
foundation did you know him no and I
went to his funeral I felt very strongly
having met him about him I had known her
blocks cartoons you know for years and I
expected someone much sharper and
tougher when I walked in to photograph
him at the washington post and i found
the nicest gentlemen I'd almost met in
the news business and he was absolutely
charming and wonderful claude pepper
1982 flower senator a former quarter
senator former congressman I went to
photograph him and I was having it i was
using lights in this portrait and i was
having a terrible time with the
reflection in his glasses and he
understood that right away and he said
Oh a little lady just a minute and he
reached his truck never forget this he
reached in his drawer and he pulled out
a pair of glasses that had no lenses in
them and he took off his real glasses
put on the ones with no lenses and said
I bet you have no reflection now and it
was just fantastic it was a real bro we
can see it that closely here oh the
reflection yes or lack thereof now you
have a number of pictures in here like
this of people other than yeah but not a
lot and have you done a lot of that
other kind of photography over the years
yes Brian I only covered the White House
on an every other month Bay
with my colleagues and so I had a lot of
free time every other month and so I did
all kinds of different photography for
time and for other magazines along the
line 1985 Edward Chevron Ozzy now the
president of Georgia George Shultz yes
President Reagan this was a very tense
moment really we had President Reagan
was about to meet with Gorbachev and
sort of as a precursor I think to that
meeting he what he was at the United
Nations and there was talk about him
meeting with the Foreign Minister
shevardnadze and no one knew it was
going to happen or not and we had a
rumor that they were both going to be at
a reception together at the Waldorf went
running over got the picture Oval Office
some familiar faces is this is a
behind-the-scenes picture in color
because we hadn't moved really into the
idea of using black and white behind the
scenes when this picture was taken and
it was just interesting to us to see
that was his chief of staff at the time
Donald Regan and his national security
advisor but McFarland and Secretary of
State Schultz there's a you can't see it
we can't get a whole lot closer but
there's a blue folder on his desk and it
says information for the price for the
President and right below it says
information are they ever nervous about
you taking too close to photographs of
what's up President's desk they are I
have actually been asked on at least two
occasions not to use a picture after
I've been in a room and photographed
something they've realized that the
information on the desk was sensitive it
was top secret and that's something
certainly Time magazine cooperates with
and we pulled the pictures and didn't
consider them for use the meeting with
mr. Gorbachev is this a particularly
important day it was particularly
important yes it was Gorbachev's first
visit to the White House
to visit President Reagan and I had
asked to see them privately at some
point during the summit and that wasn't
very easy to deliver yes this is
exclusive he was Gorbachev was leaving
one of the sessions going back to
wherever he was staying blair house I
guess and Reagan walked him down the
driveway this is North Carolina November
fourth 1983 yes what's the story I
remember this very very well it seemed
to me during the eight years the
Reagan's were in the White House an
awful lot of very sad events happened
the Challenger blew up and this was
again another memorial service it was
for the Marines who were lost in the
terrible bombing and Lebanon on the
following page the Pope yes this is just
an open photo op of opportunity of the
Pope meeting with President Reagan but I
just thought it was beautiful you can
just see the faces of some of the other
participants and it was just a lovely
press opportunity at the end of a
meeting Ronald Reagan with his first
lady yes that again is behind the scenes
I just remember that I think they were
going out for a state arrival and mrs.
Reagan was having a little quiet time
with the president before they went out
and on the following page where's that
President Reagan had been ill in
bethesda naval hospital with colon
cancer and he returned to the White
House and he came back you know
characteristically full of vigor and
enthusiasm and that was when he walked
into the White House with the Queen
this picture has been seen quite a lot
people seem to be amused by it it's a
picture that was taken at a state dinner
in San Francisco after the Queen had
been the Reagan's guest visiting
california and it had rained and rained
and rained for her entire visit and
never stopped raining and she made a
toast at this dinner where she said that
she knew that the Puritans when they
came to the new world had brought many
carry many of customs from her land but
she had no idea they'd also brought the
rotten weather and the president just
loves that 135 pictures yes ever kind of
how many pictures you've taken in your
life no I haven't I wouldn't want to it
would be frightening and what is a book
like this cost to buy this book for cost
forty dollars picture of George Herbert
Walker Bush serious expression 1990
Prague Czechoslovakia how close are you
to him at this point I was about 10 feet
away from him he and vaclav havel had
come out of a meeting in Prague and had
were having a press conference and so of
course the news picture that I was
taking and we were all taking was the
two of them together at the microphones
talking to the press however often in
situations like that if you look at your
subject alone you might see something
and I saw a cold strong-looking George
Bush and was able to just simply make a
portrait of him alone and it I told him
when i went to show him the pictures
about the book you see in the picture in
the book as you know i have comments by
all the presidents and first ladies on
these pictures not all the pictures but
a lot of them and when I showed this to
President Bush and mrs. Bush looked at
it and she said oh doesn't he look
handsome
I said yes mrs. Bush this is my George
Bush Clint Eastwood look alike and they
both very amused that back in 1979 you
have this picture with lots of faces in
it elie wiesel is at the podium and it's
in the rotunda the US Capitol and right
here is the president and right over
here is Senator Bob Byrd vice president
Mondale there why did you choose this
picture you know I picked it because it
was different I picked it because there
was something to me about President
Carter sitting alone surrounded by all
these people not looking to me exactly
like one of them he looked alone to me
and I I just liked the the feeling of
the picture of him in the center and all
the players around him did you ever have
a present ask you for a photo after you
taken it after yeah I was a absolutely
no they're always followed by their own
photographers oh yes I have and in fact
in in the book is a picture that I took
of President Clinton working with his
speech writers on the on the upcoming I
guess it was a state of the union speech
and to get him surrounded by all of his
speech writers I went around his desk in
the Oval Office and I looked across his
desk and as I did I noticed right in the
center of his desk a picture that I had
taken of the president and mrs. Clinton
and Chelsea that he'd asked me for and
dissing right here yes and there it was
and you can imagine I was thrilled I
looked and I said oh my heavens
president has my picture right in the
center of his desk and so when that
picture ran the following week in time I
called up my editor and I said I want
you to know I'm that picture has two of
my pictures the mat that page has two of
my pictures on it the main one and the
picture of the president and Chelsea and
mrs. Glynn we're back to some more of
Bill Clinton here is a picture from 1996
you know this picture to me or it's in
the book because to me it was it
reminded me of a sort of a
quintessential Clinton moment this poor
lady who was 90-some years old at the
time 98 or something began to faint from
the heat and everybody went around her
and revived her and brought her up and
the president was concerned and he
stopped doing whatever he was doing and
walked down to her he put his arm around
her and he spoke to her and he greeted
her and he made her feel so much better
and then he discovered it was her
birthday and he turned around went back
up on the stage took her with him and
had the entire rally sing happy birthday
well I mean you know this is some
politician what are you what's your beat
now my beat I have no beat I'm on
contract to time I'm doing special
projects i'm doing a few things here and
there that they want me to do and i'm
very happy to do i was wanted to leave
the White House after 23 years Brian
that was long enough do you have another
goal of you know I assume this book was
my is this your first book yes yes it's
my first book of my own yes and what do
you think of the experience well it was
a fascinating experience to me it made
me well begin to look at the body of my
work and it made me realize what I'd
seen which you know when you're working
every day you kind of forget how you
know it's it's funny to think of
spending so much time watching
presidents when so many people never see
one in their lifetime
and so I began to sort of appreciate the
experience and I'm going back and
looking more closely at everything and
I'm having a retrospective next winter
of my work not only the presidential but
the other things I was doing in the
months off so i'm reviewing everything
right now and it's kind of fun where
will the retrospective be at the
Smithsonian's Museum of American History
for how long I don't know how many
photos I don't know it's all being
formulated right now why did you put
this in the book I love that picture Joe
Califano and Dan sure 1976 I know were
you doing then I was it was on
assignment in this picture actually for
the Village Voice and I was doing a
story on Dan shore because he had given
the The Village Voice in fact the pike
report which had fallen into his hands
which was a report done by the
congressman congressional committee on
some of the well it was criticisms at
that time of the FBI and the CIA and
they hauled Dan shore up in front of the
house to question him about where he
what his sources were and true to his
journalistic integrity he refused to
divulge his source and it was very
interesting time interesting story
captain Hill 1975 George Wallace yes
that's a just a was a surprise picture I
was leaving a hearing and I walked out
in the hall and there was a governor
Wallace and I had actually seen him only
once before in my life down in Talladega
Alabama when he was campaigning with his
wife Lurlene who was running for
governor and I hadn't seen him since he
had been shot and there he was with his
then wife and in his wheelchair
President Ford Henry Kissinger 1975 yes
well why not I was at the White House he
was saying goodbye to a foreign
dignitary I can't remember who right now
but when I went to talk to him he will
President Ford was wonderful talking
about all of these pictures to me he is
this one of bob dole he'd chosen bob
dole to run with him in 1976 and he
commented to me and what a really
wonderful sense of humor senator dole
had what funny was to have with him on
the ticket when you worked with a
different presents first ladies for
their little squibs in the book how did
that how did you do that what I did was
I didn't know at the time that I went to
see each of the presidents and first
ladies exactly which book which pictures
were going to end up in the book because
that as you know is a an editing
decision that's made really quite late
in the game and so what i did was i just
took i call up each president and asked
if I could come visit bringing my tape
recorder to ask them about certain
images that I and I just took a bunch of
images some I thought would probably be
in the book some weren't in the book in
the end and I didn't want to show them
all anyway that's an imposition the time
would have been enormous so I just went
to see each and every one of them and
talk to them and they would look at the
picture and tell me what they thought
was going on or how they felt about it
or this particular situation and then I
brought these back to the National
Geographic and the editor Leah Ben David
Val and I and Becky Lascars who helped
me with the words matched what they said
to the pictures that we ended up using
and that's how we felt it would make the
book more personal the book is personal
because it's my observations of the
presidencies as I saw them my favorite
pictures and then some of the situations
are quite personal the presidents are in
in this book and so to have them talk
about the pictures we thought just
enhanced the
walk which president spent the most time
with you golly they all spent just as
long as I wanted I can't tell you that
any weren't able to see yes I was not
able to see the Carters and so I spoke
did it over the phone with them because
our schedules Justin didn't work and I
must say it was better being with the
presidents in person than it was to do
it over the phone that was more
difficult when did you talk to Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan of course is the
exception I spoke at length with mrs.
Reagan but there are two comments that
President Reagan made to me back in
nineteen ninety in writing about the
Queen's picture and about the Laughing
picture that you showed and I'm so
pleased I have these comments about the
pictures to be able to put them in the
book so his voice is in the book this
picture of Nelson Rockefeller 1974 why
is it included there's his wife happy
it's included because that was one of
the first pictures that I think I ever
took as a professional photographer it
was the confirmation hearings of Nelson
Rockefeller who was vice president under
Gerald Ford when he became president
when Nixon resigned when I first came to
town you could go to the San Souci
restaurant which you can see right up
here down there on fourteenth Street
near the White House that's the but i
think it's the renwick gallery branwen
there's art book while standing out
there the restaurants not there any
longer it's mcdonalds why this picture
well you know in the book I have broken
up each chapter of the president's with
other players who've been in Washington
observing Washington participating in
other ways to give you just a feeling
for the other players and also to break
the book up a bit and you can't have a
book about Washington and the presidency
without without our Buckwald here's a
big picture you have a number of these
real close shot yes
do these men know that they're always
being photographed this closely no of
course not they know we're in the room
and certainly I wasn't very I wasn't
standing that close to President Ford in
that picture I was step I was back but
that's when a single lens reflex comes
in handy when you have a longer lens on
it because you can frame the picture
exactly the way you want and if you have
a zoom lens you can come in and go out
this one's in color and it's back in
nineteen ninety-three I believe or did
you take this that picture was actually
taken that picture is in the national
portrait gallery I want you to know and
I'm very proud of that but that is not a
sitting I did not conceive of that
background I did not set this picture up
at all this picture was taken in fact at
a rally or an event for I believe social
security in Baltimore where the
president was appearing big picture in
other words a big displayed picture in
1990 Saudi Arabia you were there I won't
care yes I was there and that picture in
fact won first prize in World Press for
a news picture which makes me very proud
we'd gone with the bushes to Saudi
Arabia for Thanksgiving just just a
short time before what was known as
Desert Storm against Iraq Tom Foley oh
yeah Tom Foley went on that went on that
trip to the desert that day with the
President as did there was a
congressional delegation with him how
often are you surprised by who's in a
picture when you take a picture of the
principal then you look around bingo
there in the background somebody didn't
expect oh well you could say that about
this picture but but one of the one of
the more amusing pictures in the book i
think is is is an image that i had no
idea of who the man was in in the image
when i took it and that is it's a
picture of which appears in the Carter
section in the front of the book it's a
picture of mrs. Carter in our
saw and in the picture with her is the
governor of Arkansas and I have to tell
you that I had absolutely no idea that
mrs. Carter that I had ever seen
governor a governor Clinton until I said
yes yeah 1979 and I never I never knew
that I'd seen governor Clinton before he
came to Washington as president-elect
the interesting thing about this picture
is Rosa Parks them I know and it's Rosa
Parks who I have never seen with dark
hair because I've seen her more recently
with gray hair and I was so surprised
when my friend Mary done who help me
edit the pictures for the book and went
through the time-life picture collection
she said wait till you see this picture
did you know you photographed governor
Clinton I said what she said with Rosa
Parks iswhat so of course I had to put
it in the book we don't have a whole lot
of time left and I want to make sure as
we haven't shown all the pictures is
Eric one or two in here that we haven't
shown that you consider to be your
favorite well there's a picture in there
that I love of President Clinton taking
a deep breath before he before he went
up to accept the nomination the second
time for president and it was so
extraordinary because he was I was
behind the stage with him and suddenly
they announced his name over the
loudspeaker and he took this enormous
deep breath as if to say here I go and I
thought to myself someone as as such a
pro as President Clinton has to take a
deep breath just like I would have to go
out and stand there in front of those
thousands and thousands of people and
make a speech in the same grouping here
there's a picture I want to ask you
about it i can find it quickly enough
there are a number including
okay oh this one yeah yes well you had
to have chosen that because that picture
is extraordinary you got Secretary of
Defense president secretary of state
sandy Berger yeah what happened there
was I was in a holding room behind the
scenes just me there with them and I
asked President Clinton what in the
world happened at that moment he said
well I I think that we were all just
sort of sitting in a row we were a
little bored we were waiting for an
event to begin and we were in the
holding room and I kind of looked around
and said gosh we look like those monkeys
hear no evil see no evil so suddenly
they just simply did it and I thought am
I seeing things and I you know I
sometimes when you know you have a
picture you can just quietly get up and
walk out of the room well I quietly got
up and walked out of the room then close
by as this photograph here that is of a
different kind oh yes that's an in
public and that picture to me says you
know this is what it's like this is what
it's like to meet a presently United
States this happened all the time with
every president after he would speak
he'd go walk the rope line at the front
of the audience and I mean not only of
course do I find the ladies amusing who
seemed to be nearly a swooning but in
the background there are these men and
women who brought their own Instamatic
seeeeee to a very fancy party in New
York to photograph the President of the
United States where did you take this
picture that picture was just taken in
one of those events in the old executive
office building President Reagan had met
with state troopers and they gave him a
hat and you know to me it shows the
confidence of President Reagan because
not many politicians will take a hat and
put it on their head when they haven't
tried it on first because often it'll
come down to their nose or else it'll on
the top of his head and President Reagan
just didn't care he put it right on and
put it on a sort of a rakish angle how
many photographs did you want to put in
this book that you didn't get in after
you had 135 in a hand did you have a
stack up
yes I did put them in any I'm on the
internet or any place we can see more
Diana Walker photos well it at yes it at
time.com their picture stories go way
way back of mine yes but maybe i'll do
another book it's a thought and on that
note we're out of time this is what the
book looks like it's called public and
private 20 years of photographing the
presidency Diana Walker with a foreword
by Michael Beschloss we thank you very
much thank you very much